a u.s jury has cleared teenager kyle
rittenhouse of all charges in a dramatic
trial that has become a flashpoint in
the nation's debate over guns and racial
injustice
the 18-year-old broke down as the
verdict was read he could have faced
life in prison after shooting dead two
people and seriously wounding a third
during a black lives matter protest last
year the case has divided opinion in the
u.s with critics and supporters
gathering outside the courthouse in
anticipation of today's verdict
was it an act of self-defense or
gratuitous violence
that was a question faced by 12 jurors
as the u.s awaited the verdict of kyle
rittenhouse
he was just 17 years old when he shot
dead two people and injured a third in
kenosha wisconsin last august
protests swept through the city after
police shot a black man jacob blake
leaving him partially paralyzed
it came just three months after the
murder of george floyd an incident that
stunned the world and left america
reeling
sparking a wave of anti-racism
demonstrations at the height of the
covid pandemic
rittenhouse said he was there to protect
property and provide first aid
he traveled there from neighboring
illinois with a semi-automatic rifle
reportedly given to him by a friend
protesters in support of and against
written house gathered outside kenosha
county courthouse in the run-up to the
verdict
the judge had pleaded with the jury to
set aside political and public
commentary and focus strictly on the
facts
but in a case that crystallized the
country's polarizing views on the issues
of race police violence and growing
vigilantism
today's outcome has implications far
beyond those for kyle rittenhouse
joining us for more is dw correspondent
oliver salad he's outside the courthouse
in kenosha where the trial was held
oliver welcome to the program describe
the scene inside the court as the
verdict came in
michael i just left the courtroom and of
course as you can imagine the motions
were running very high as the
jurors read out their verdicts first of
all kyle rittenhouse the defendant broke
down essentially shaking all over his
body was then escorted out of the
courtroom very quickly after that and in
contrast the family members of the
victims
crying sobbing as they left the
courtroom
outside here some people honking their
horns celebrating others frustrated
arguing debating i can't believe that
this has really happened and of course
we shouldn't forget michael that this is
not only about the town of kenosha this
is a co this is a trial that was
followed very closely all across the
united states that divides the nation
and so a lot of people will be either
relieved or very frustrated with today's
today's verdict oliver as you well know
we cannot overstate how highly
anticipated this verdict was is there
concern at this hour about how
communities are going to react to this
verdict particularly those communities
that were involved in these racial
justice protests in the first place
now of course there are concerns
especially here in kenosha because let's
remind our viewers when this happened
here when kyle rittenhouse
shot at those three of those three
people here those were blm protesters
that night taking to the street in
support of jacob blake
that black man that was shot by a white
police officer so a lot of people here
will be frustrated the question is will
they come will they come out will they
protest tonight we can hear some
helicopters in the sky but overall the
situation here at least in kenosha on
the ground has been very quiet as of now
and let's not forget again that there's
a bigger question you know behind all
this a lot of people and critics are
concerned that this is a blueprint now
for people
essentially saying that this ruling
means it's okay to take your gun your
assault rifle on a protest and then act
in self-defense later and a lot of other
questions that follow is this a question
of white privilege for instance that
verdict that we had here today questions
of gun laws will be asked that are
dividing the nation as well and perhaps
the most important question what would
have happened um if kyle rittenhouse was
a black citizen would we have seen
another verdict then
oliver uh before this verdict came in of
course there was a request from the
defense for a mistrial
on what basis did they ask for the judge
to throw this case out
yeah there were several of those
requests but perhaps the most important
one was the one that we heard
just in the final days here
it was about drone footage that was shot
about the drone footage of the last
shots that he fired on mr rosenbaum the
first victim
and the
defendants say that that footage was not
handed over to them in full resolution
whereas the prosecution had full
resolution so they saw some kind of a
disadvantage over there look
since there is a verdict now and the
verdict is not guilty all those bids
are not relevant anymore because kyle
rittenhouse is now unguilty on all
counts that's right uh oliver salad in
kenosha many thanks oliver